[Musik]
nur ja keine zeit verlieren
der st galler bauingenieur bodner
roethlisberger setzt alles daran dass
die arbeiten in diesem tunnel schnell
vorwärts gehen
wir sind im kaukasus im süden russlands
nahe der stadt sotschi diese tunnel
skript russland für die olympischen
winterspiele 2014
die olympiade 2014 findet
durch den was alles fertig 7
unterscheidet von der hauptaufgaben von
mir termine so der kontrolle dass man
das auch richtig erreichen
die winterspiele von sotschi haben
bereits verlierer what a feeling gehört
dazu
er war einst der bekannteste tourismus
pionier in dieser version und baute an
einem ferienort nach schweizer vorbild
doch der staat macht es einen traum
zunichte
wir hatten ganz andere pläne für unser
dorf was jetzt abläuft ist gigantismus
sie sind durchaus zufrieden wie russland
in sotschi die teuersten winterspiele
aller zeiten vorbereitet die delegierten
des internationalen olympischen komitees
ioc
der franzose jean claude killy leitet
die subkommission der schweizer rené
fasel unterstützt ihn basel gibt sich
zuversichtlich
seit der vergabe glaubte fest daran
wladimir putin wird es richten natürlich
denn zum präsidenten putin ist natürlich
[Musik]
juli 2007 in guatemala
russland jubelt zuschlag für die
winterspiele 2014 in sotschi renommierte
gegner wie zb salzburg sind chancenlos
gegen geld und macht putins er will
diese spiele unbedingt und garantiert
milliarden-investitionen
[Applaus]
verspricht alles wird rechtzeitig fertig
an jenem tag fiel in sotschi der
startschuss zum größten prestige projekt
la die mir.de ins
die russen liebten sie eigentlich als
sommerferien ort die stadt liegt am
schwarzen meer etwa auf den breitengrad
von st tropez wintersport interessierte
hier kaum jemanden
[Musik]
inzwischen aber zieht russland am
subtropischen strand modernste
eissporthallen hoch
[Musik]
die regierung ließ zuvor hunderte häuser
abreißen die bewohner würden oft
zwangsenteignet im besten fall gab es in
solchen neue siedlungen eine
ersatzwohnung
sotschi ist derzeit wohl die größte
baustelle europas mit weit über 50.000
arbeiter neue straßen und bahnen werden
taleinwärts gebaut 50 km lang zum dorf
krasnaja poljana auf 600 metern
meereshöhe dieser ort so zum mekka des
russischen sports werden
gebaut wird das meiste innerhalb des
sotschi nationalparks der möglich durch
gesetzesänderungen dem russischen
parlament locker durchkamen
geld scheint dabei keine rolle zu
spielen
allein die neue eisenbahn- und
straßenverbindungen zwischen sony und
dem dorf krasnaja poljana kostet fast 8
milliarden franken so viel hatte man
einst für den gotthard tunnel geplant
bruno roethlisberger 64 jährige arbeitet
für die schweizer firma amberg
engineering den auftrag als experte und
berater erhielt er im januar 2009 von
den russischen eisenbahnen
das olympische komitee hatte von den
losen verlangt einen ausländischen
experten hinzuzuziehen es befürchtete
dass es knapp werden könnte mit der
fertigstellung des tunnels bis 2014
über den vorschlag und dann raus
straßen tunnel raus transparente
woche ist fertig
dann haben wir auch ruhe damit für den
vor dem durchschlag wirklich schnell
machen können und keine wendung mehr
haben
die geologischen studien der gegend
waren wegen des zeitdrucks ungenügend
roethlisberger und sein team sahen darin
viele risiken so stellte er im winter
2009 fest dass drei tunnel ausgänge in
diesem schlammigen rutschen geplant
waren da schlug ihr sofort alarm
beiden aber trotzdem das ganze kostet
uns gefühlt modell da die partie trüb
tunnel zum berges führen also der road
to nowhere
zentimeter service tunnel und bergwärts
der tunnel hätten einige
überzeugungsarbeit gebraucht was der
rutsch masse modano 100 die vermieter
nach uv das risiko könnte sie für die
ganze tunnel das risiko werden sie war
hätte die tunnel den dort baut wenn man
dann tunnelte europa die rutschbahn aber
trug toto dass der tunnel immer mehr so
hat weder verschoben werden und
vielleicht zum einbruch hätte keine
führer und war vielleicht halbe olympia
denn wer ist fertig sie das nicht die
die die schnellbahn rufe gott doch nicht
einfach noch mal schnell irgendwas
machen
nach roethlisbergers intervention
änderten die russen ihre pläne mit
dieser großen hängebrücke kann der
rutschung umfahren werden
[Musik]
die idee dazu kam von gruner
roethlisberger aber es war
premierminister wladimir putin der das
definitiver ok zu dieser variante gab
und dann 25 26 dezember bin ich hoffe
regie der schweiz sie uns telefonisch
ist er geprüfter stunden ein big boss
werner sprecher wladimir putin hegi
ausrichten dass motorvariante betone
lindenberg und rot tunnel in der
felswand in den fluss oder mitriss
albbruck zu realisieren ist das einmal
dass sich die entschädigung putin teil
ich denke dieser große projekt um weiß
dass wladimir putin natürlich an
oberster stelle die wichtigsten
entscheid fällt denken ist das natürlich
normal und technische sondern
entscheiden auch eine neue politik
umgesetzt worden
sotschi ist das prestige-projekt von
wladimir putin
gute freunde wie letztes jahr silvio
berlusconi hätte am liebsten hierher ein
[Musik]
und putin hat sein versprechen ans ioc
gehalten er ist oft vor ort und
kontrolliert selber wie die arbeiten in
sotschi vorwärts gehen
[Musik]
putin und medwedjew zeigen sich auch
regelmäßig beim skifahren zu ziehen
beste werbung für die region sotschi als
austragungsort für winterspiele diese
wahl hat das olympische komitee bis
heute nicht bereut
beim après ski herrscht beste stimmung
zwischen den ioc-delegierten kiel ii und
phase und den russischen machthabern
medwedew und putin
wenn ihr phasen zeigt sich überzeugt
putin profitiert dass die olympischen
spiele in seinem land stattfinden
sowie nähert so zum sport steht also
sehr gut
das begriffen dass es ist anzunehmen
dass man also wintersport und ich so
dramatisch
wird das sehr wirkt sich natürlich denn
mit olympische spiele vorwärtsgang oder
wenn ihr möglich seo in russland war
vorwärts gab ist das jetzt machen soll
im wasser spielen aber auch für fasel
und das olympische komitee ist russland
ein gewinn es gehört zu den wichtigsten
wachstumsmärkten für die wintersport
industrie und im ioc bringt es
milliardeneinnahmen von neuen sponsoren
und vermarktungsrechten
russland lässt sich so die kosten über
30 milliarden franken sollen insgesamt
in die olympia stadt fließen
das ist eine berechtigte frage für mich
gar nicht aber neue die ambitionen von
einem landung oder sie wäre mancher
wintersportort wh weiß ja keiner
größter land vorgewarnt vergessen etwas
rot wie zermatt oder sankt moritz oder
gewerblich 100 jahre händler wenn man
das vlt somit straße gemacht hätte bahn
macht hat mit
dem klub dass minister macht
zwei jahre noch laufen die bauarbeiten
auf hochtouren in sotschi werden so
viele sport disziplinen durchgeführt wie
noch nie es braucht tausende hotelzimmer
medienzentren sportanlagen straßen die
umweltbilanz ist umstritten die
organisatoren sprechen von grünen
spielen umweltschützer sagen aber das
einmalige ökosystem in diesem berg tal
werte nachhaltig geschädigt
wenn wir kritische fragen darzustellen
heißt es ihr habt ja in der schweiz auch
eure wintersportorte gebaut so ähnlich
sieht es das olympische komitee auch
beim thema umwelt ist man mit putin
zufrieden
wer putins einbrecher haben wir bewusst
den menschen was man sieht aber dass man
merkt dass hier ein auto wie sie burda
du bist wie sie der natur ii greife hier
hat am löffel kritiker von natur
verweise das ist natürlich groß aber
ethische mauer
naturschützer erwarten ist dass dem user
nichts freude sie die müser ja ihre
aufgabe das sind jetzt freute sich das
enorme und das ist ein echter soll
ein wintersportort im alten stil in
harmonie mit der umwelt das war sein
großes ziel lottofee den gebirgslagen
jahr hatte hier in krasnaya polyana in
den 90er jahren die ersten ski und
sessellifte gebaut als sehr
erfolgreicher privatunternehmer mit rund
500 angestellten
wo einst seine ski piste war entsteht
jetzt die neue bobbahn für olympia den
kritisiert die chaotische bautätigkeit
jeder bauer nach seinem gusto erzählt er
uns fehlen selber wurde von
staatsbeamten lange drangsaliert und
unter druck gesetzt
schließlich gab er auf und verkaufte
sein tourismusunternehmen an eine
staatliche rohstoff firma weit unter dem
marktwert
privatunternehmer wie er sind nicht
erwünscht in putins milliarden schon
[Musik]
so wie das hier abläuft hat mir keine
chance mehr unsere tourismus pläne zu
verwirklichen
darum habe ich alles verkauft es gibt ja
spezielle gesetze wie die olympischen
spiele
diese erlauben es den beamten sich alles
zu nehmen was sie wollen und man kann
sich nicht mal einen richter wenden
bei der standortwahl für die
sportanlagen habe man auf den rat von
einheimischen spezialisten verzichtet
das führe zu fehlentscheidungen und
sinnlose geldverschwendung
man hätte die sportanlagen viel
überlegter bauen und viel geld einsparen
können schauen sie doch wo die
sprungschanzen stehen
ein völlig sinnlose ort mit einer extrem
teuren straßenverbindung
rund 140 millionen franken kosten die
neuen sprungschanzen zehnmal mehr als
die schweizer chancen in einsiedeln im
dorf krasnaja poljana seien heute viele
menschen der olympiade überdrüssig sagt
fehling baulärm und dreck rund um die
uhr haben spuren hinterlassen
was ihn aber besonders beschäftigt ist
die frage der nachhaltigkeit
zwar entstehen jetzt moderne skigebiete
und viele hotelbetten aber eher
bezweifelt ob sich das alles nach den
olympischen spielen jemals rentabel
betreiben lässt
hier wird alles wie die olympischen
spiele gebaut das tut einem sehr weh auf
die natur wird viel zu wenig rücksicht
genommen den gepflegten winterkurort den
wir mit unseren generalplan angestrebt
hatten wird es nie mehr geben das hier
ist industrieller tourismus hohe bauten
viel beton und wenig holzverkleidung das
wird noch viele probleme geben
die frage der nachhaltigkeit stellt sich
tatsächlich in sotschi vor allem bei den
neuen verkehrsverbindungen ins tal es
gibt bereits heute eine gute straße nach
krasnaja poljana aber für die
winterspiele lässt putin jetzt noch eine
zusatz straße und eine
hochgeschwindigkeitsbahn bauen
im werbefilm sieht das so aus mit bis zu
200 stundenkilometern donnern die züge
von sochi er mehr bis ins skigebiet die
neue straße und eisenbahn bieten eine
transportkapazität von sage und schreibe
20.000 menschen pro stunde
ein luxus für die winterspiele fast acht
milliarden franken teuer
allerdings es sind nicht nur die
technischen herausforderungen die die
tunnels straßen und olympischen anlagen
in sotschi außergewöhnlich teuer machen
es ist die rede von riesigen
schmiergeldern die vor allem daran
schuld sein
ein bekanntes phänomen in putins
russland was meinst tunnel experte
roethlisberger dazu
also ich habe da einen technischen
auftrag risk management und bauherr
begleitet und mit der bauhaus stadt
nicht
direkt zur aber da hört eilig sozialen
auch dass die dritte prozent über sind
wir in mitteleuropa sondern dass sie
doch einiges höher sind die
vorstellungen mit
angebot und nachfrage und der konkurrenz
laufen oder rohde späth mitglied wie sie
in europa stieg in europa dietz
international news schrieb wo unter
härtesten konkurrenzkampf noch ein
unternehmen darüber zu wachen das läuft
in russland und die wände projekte etwas
handeln
wie
indem er hat direktvergabe gemacht werde
das unternehmen ein unterwegs wo fähig
ist das machen und die unternehmer
darfst du machst federführend sich
unfähig das machen
[Musik]
der und am ende darf sie hat sich meiner
kenntnis
roethlisberger sagt er sei durchaus wohl
nichts mit der kostenkontrolle zu tun zu
haben als berater und experte kann und
will er sich da raushalten
[Musik]
aber firmen und unternehmer müssen
angeblich riesige schmiergelder an
beamte bezahlen wenn sie hier aufträge
erhalten wollen
darüber klagen bekannte russische
oppositionspolitiker und auch
unternehmer selber
[Musik]
die rede ist von mehreren milliarden
franken schmiergeldern es sind solche
summen die mit erklären warum die kosten
für das projekt sotschi auf über 30
milliarden angestiegen sind
[Applaus]
wir haben letztes jahr mit rico sack den
stellvertretenden regierungschef von
wladimir putin mit den
korruptionsvorwürfen
konfrontiert
russische oppositionelle sagen die
kostenüberschreitungen seien auf
korruption und schmiergelder
zurückzuführen was sagen sie dazu
zu korruption schmiergeld und
unterschlagung halte ich nochmals fest
wir sind zivilisierte leute von
korruption und schmiergeldern kann erst
die rede sein wenn es entsprechende
anklagen und rechtskräftige urteile gibt
aber solche gerichtsurteile gibt es
nicht
[Musik]
in einem rechtsstaat wäre das ein
überzeugendes argument aber in russland
wo heute eine elite aus politik
geheimdienst und rohstoffwirtschaft über
dem gesetz steht bleiben fragen offen
fragen die beim olympischen komitee
nicht im vordergrund stehen sich das ist
das thema wenn die wirte antwort finden
würde es machen aber das ist sehr
schwierig und sogar stabiler machen aber
das modell setzt sich natürlich
rücksetzer das ist das ist sicherer als
thema war besprochen dabei mache einen
fehler gemacht
die vorfreude auf die winterspiele will
man sich im kaukasus nicht vermiesen
lassen vor drei wochen führte sotschi
die ersten weltcup rennen durch das
internationale lohn war groß
hervorragende pisten und eine gute
organisation
[Musik]
im zielraum ein hauch von moskau az ein
neuer ort wo sich russische politik und
oligarch ii treffen können auch
russische milliardäre investieren in
sotschi beträchtliche summen es heißt
wladimir putin habe entsprechend druck
gemacht wie er es oft tut bei solchen
projekten
[Musik]
der multi milliardär wladimir potanin
hat für sein neues iris so weit über
eine milliarde franken investiert
freiwillig meinte er
[Musik]
ich hatte diese idee selber ich bin oft
in der schweiz frankreich und österreich
und habe dann entschieden dass russland
seinen eigenen winterferien ort haben
sollte
mutina diese idee gefallen und er hat
mich auf unterstützt
es bleibt offen ob sich die investierten
milliarden lohnen und was die
olympischen spiele dem land tatsächlich
bringen werden auch noch-präsident
mittel medwedew aber der weltcup
premiere in sotschi mit dabei
der präsident eine frage fürs schweizer
fernsehen welche sie haben hier ein sehr
teures projekt was bringt das russland
wissen sie sport gibt eine andere kultur
und eine andere lebensqualität wenn ein
land solche anlagen baut und die
olympischen winterspiele durchführt dann
ändert sich auch die atmosphäre
interessante worte aber 2014 wird mit
vegf nicht mehr präsident sein
[Musik]
und bis zu den winterspielen bleibt auch
noch viel zu tun der schweizer tunnel
fachmann bonner roethlisberger macht
weiter zeitdruck
gemäss plan sind ja im programm aber man
könnte schneller sein
und die zeit die wir jetzt einsparen
würden
diese zeit hätten wir nachher zur
verfügung für den endausbau
das wäre doch besser
einfach sagen wir haben programm wir
sind nach brauchen das stimmt alles
stimmt alles aber besser wäre es sorgt
machen fertig machen roethlisbergers
vertrag wurde kürzlich um ein weiteres
jahr verlängert damit mitte 2000 und
tritt somit also bauarbeiten fertig sie
und die organisation was da noch alles
sehen wir trainieren muss in den tunnel
wo jetzt erst durchschlagen ist bald
werden das ist enorm und das buch
gewaltige organisation
koordination und kommunikation das auto
service wo in russland sehr offen wir
bedeutet also mit einem kombi zieren
große sorgen braucht sich roethlisberger
nicht zu machen so lange wladimir putin
in russland der starke mann ist bleibt
das olympia projekt auf gutem wege
für seine milliarden show wird putin so
viele rubel locker machen wie es eben
braucht
[Musik]